- We've teamed up with Go RVing
to travel from Dallas to Waco,
which is such a beautiful drive.
And there are so many nontraditional trips
that you can take with your RV.
And this road trip
with Barrymore was
anything but conventional.
Wait till you see this.
(Drew claps)
(upbeat music)
(horn honks)
Hello, Texas!
Drew, Look here, we are
at Trinity Overlook Park,
the Dallas Skyline behind us.
This is a dream come true for me.
I have always wanted to go RVing,
and I know that you are an expert.
- I've been RVing since
I had a driver's license.
There really is no better way to travel.
- Well, I have some stipulations
if we're gonna go in an RV trip, okay.
Number one, we need eat
good road trip snacks.
- Like beef jerky?
- Yes, that's exactly what I'm thinking.
- I can't road trip without beef jerky.
- And number two, can I drive?
- Well, I'm used to driving,
but I'll be in your
passenger's seat any day
of the week.
- Yeah!
My big rig awaits.
Let's start with a little beef
jerky first, just for energy.
Say RV on three.
One, two, three, RV!
(camera clicks)
- I have a mouth full of
jerky, I can't say it.
(RV engine roars)
- Yeah!
- [Drew] We're actually
driving at five miles an hour.
Can you believe that?
- All right, let's do this.
(horn honking)
Excuse me.
I think we're getting on the freeway.
This is going to be a moment.
- You're graduating.
- We went from side street
to freeway real quick.
(truck horn honking)
What are road trip games?
I should have Googled it.
You remember I spy?
- All right, let's play I spy.
- How does it work again?
I see something, you have
to figure out what it is.
- Which is gonna be hard
while we're driving.
(laughing together)
- It doesn't work.
- Do you wanna count how
many times I get honked at?
(Drew laughs)
(horn honks)
That was one.
I love that nod
that people do like this when
you drive by someone like.
Do you ever do that?
And like a one hand up wave?
- It gives me a lot of this.
(laughing together)
- I love that you're all
sunshiney and hi everybody.
I love you.
- Put a steering wheel in front of me
and I turn into the exorcist.
- Oh, can we try barbecue?
- Yes, of course.
(horn honks)
Hello.
- Hello, hi.
We want some barbecue.
- You're in the right spot.
- [Ross] So what makes
your barbecue so delicious?
- Well, we're famous for the brisket
and we were voted one of the
top 50 in "Texas Monthly".
- How does Texas do barbecue?
- Oh, Texas style barbecue
is probably the best.
- Why?
- It is smoked meat.
- Can we try some barbecue?
- Oh my God, look at this!
- Oh!
(Drew screams)
No, a tisket and a tasket,
put some brisket in my basket.
- Oh my God, it's incredible.
Thank you so much.
I feel like I could eat the whole thing.
- We'll just wrap up
that whole brisket to go,
thank you.
- [Drew] Exactly!
(upbeat music)
(horns honking)
- Where's your favorite
place you've ever gone RVing?
- Joshua Tree when there
was a meteor shower.
- Wow, I used to go camping
with my parents all the time, growing up
and I would love sleeping in the RV,
sitting out by the campfire,
my parents just getting drunk.
- That's about the only thing I relate to
about any of this scenario.
- What is the most romantic movie ever?
- "Breakfast at Tiffany's".
I'm trying to think of
my favorite kiss too.
Kissing is so hot.
- It totally is.
- Oh my God.
- My first kiss with Wellie
was like 45 minutes after we met.
- Shut up, I love it.
Why waste time?
Get in there.
- Why waste time?
Are we still in Texas?
(horn honks)
Hello Waco!
Right.
- We made it!
- Thank you for making
my RV dreams come true.
- Oh my God, you're so welcome.
- One last selfie, ready?
(camera film clicks)
(audience cheer and clap)
That was so much fun.
- Oh, thank you Go RVing
for helping us take not
only such a fun trip,
but helping me realize my dreams
of talking about this on this show.
- I know, and my dream come true.
I was driving that.
You all see me driving that RV?
(audience cheer and clap)
- You manned that RV.
- That's right, I did
with my girl by my side
in the open road out there.
And for all of you at home,
RVing is for everyone,
even people who don't see them
maybe as the typical RVer,
people like me, you can trust me,
you've gotta try it.
- It's so true.
(upbeat music)